- [Voiceover] Hello
grammarians, hello Paige.
- [Voiceover] Hi, David.
- [Voiceover] So today
we're gonna tackle this idea
of what is a sentence, as we go into
this realm of language
that is called syntax.
And syntax is this concept of,
basically grammatical order.
What this word syntax
literally means in Greek,
is, you know, putting
together and arranging, right,
so it just means ordering of language.
- [Voiceover] So that's,
like, what a sentence is.
- [Voiceover] That's what a sentence is,
it's what a sentence is, it's what
the components of a sentence are.
And we'll go into all of
that in much greater detail,
but in order to do that, first of all
we have to figure out what
a sentence actually is.
So, the definition that you
and I came up with, Paige,
is that a sentence is a
grammatically complete idea.
- [Voiceover] Right.
It's a bunch of words that
say one complete thing.
- [Voiceover] So, all sentences have
a noun or pronoun component,
- [Voiceover] Mmm-hmm.
- [Voiceover] Right, and that's
what we call the subject.
And then we have the verb
part, which is the predicate.
- [Voiceover] So a sentence has,
it has to have like, a
thing, or a noun or pronoun.
- [Voiceover] Sure, that's the subject.
- [Voiceover] Yeah, and
something that it's doing.
- [Voiceover] Sure, that's the predicate.
- [Voiceover] Yeah.
- [Voiceover] Okay.
So let's say that we've got this sentence,
the great big dog
licked my face.
Here is our sentence, what is the subject?
- [Voiceover] Subject
is the great big dog.
- [Voiceover] Alright, and that means that
everything that's not the subject
is part of the predicate, right?
- [Voiceover] Mmm-hmm.
- [Voiceover] So, licked
my face is the predicate.
So this is the noun chunk that is
performing the action of the sentence.
- [Voiceover] You got it, yeah.
- [Voiceover] Cool.
So, all sentences have
to have this, right?
- [Voiceover] Yeah, they have to have
a subject and a predicate,
these two separate parts.
- [Voiceover] So if you said,
if you asked a question like,
Are you named David?
- [Voiceover] Okay,
- [Voiceover] If you asked that of me,
- [Voiceover] Mmm-hmm,
- [Voiceover] Which, go ahead.
- [Voiceover] Are you named David?
- [Voiceover] I am.
Is this a sentence, it's really short.
- [Voiceover] It is very short.
But, see, "I" is a pronoun,
- [Voiceover] Okay,
- [Voiceover] So that can be the subject.
- [Voiceover] That's our subject.
- [Voiceover] And, "am" is a verb.
So it has a subject and a predicate.
- [Voiceover] So this is
the noun or pronoun part.
And this is the action
that it is performing.
Although "am" or "being"
isn't really an action,
it's more of a linking verb.
- [Voiceover] Sure.
- [Voiceover] But it's still a verb.
- [Voiceover] Okay.
- [Voiceover] Okay, so this is, this is
the predicate then, for sure.
- [Voiceover] Yeah.
- [Voiceover] Okay, so Paige.
Let's say I dropped a muffin.
- [Voiceover] Right,
- [Voiceover] And you told
me, pick up that muffin.
- [Voiceover] Uh-huh.
- [Voiceover] That sentence
doesn't seem to have,
just let me write that down.
That sentence doesn't
seem to have a subject.
I see how all of this is predicate.
- [Voiceover] Right, pick
up is a verb, and then,
- [Voiceover] And then
the muffin is the thing
that's being picked up,
like that's all one thing.
Where's, what goes in the blue box?
- [Voiceover] I see, so when
we have a sentence like this,
where I'm telling you to do something,
- [Voiceover] Mmm-hmm,
- [Voiceover] There
doesn't always have to be
a subject said out loud.
- [Voiceover] Okay.
- [Voiceover] This is
like an order, right?
I'm telling you you have
to pick up that muffin.
- [Voiceover] So this is kinda like
an invisible, secret subject.
- [Voiceover] Right, the
subject really is you.
- [Voiceover] Okay,
- [Voiceover] You pick up that muffin,
but I don't have to say it out loud.
- [Voiceover] Because I know
that you're talking to me.
Because I can tell 'cause
you're looking at me,
and you're yelling at me about a muffin.
- [Voiceover] Yes, I am.
- [Voiceover] So, a sentence is
a grammatically complete
idea or expression.
- [Voiceover] Mmm-hmm.
- [Voiceover] And it has to
have a noun or pronoun part,
which we call the subject,
and it has to have
a verb and all it's baggage part,
which is what we call the predicate.
And sometimes that subject
can sort of be implied,
or invisible, as in the
command. "Pick up that muffin!"
- [Voiceover] Right.
- [Voiceover] Cool.
You can learn anything, David out.
- [Voiceover] Paige out.